hello my name is Jamie lacquer I am the
director of nutrition at buyers are and
today I'm happy to be here with you and
present my talk entitled improving the
post-operative recovery of rodents
through nutrition and enrichment today
I'm going to talk about the role
nutrition and enrichment can play in
proving the post-operative recovery of
rodents surgical procedures do produce
stress in animals which subsequently
alters their metabolism further pain
surgery and anesthesia can lead to a
decrease in both food and water
consumption postoperatively so this
necessitates that we want to pay
particular attention to the nutrition
the nutrition and the stress levels of
animals postoperatively specifically
paying attention to the diet composition
method of delivery and the palatability
of the diet as well as we want to do our
best to minimize introducing any
additional stress in the animals to
facilitate a quicker recovery so first
I'm going to give just lost my slides
here first I'm going to give one second
I think a little bit of problems here
with my slides I lost access to my
slides one on one moment here okay first
I'm going to talk briefly about the
metabolic changes that can occur in
response to surgery specifically I like
to give some background information just
to give you some rationale for why you
may want to include some of what I talk
about into your protocol next I'm going
to talk about what you can do from a
nutritional standpoint to help your
animals recover quickly specifically
talking about hydration acclamation diet
composition
and delivery as well as present some
data from the literature Shevin how
postoperative diets have been successful
in particular models next I'll talk
about specific specific aspects of
post-operative care specifically
focusing on ways to use enrichment to
minimize stress in the animals as well
as minimizing handling also i'll talk
about using oral dosing again to
minimize stress and handling in the
animals and then finally i'll talk about
some protocols that we've learned
working with other investigators we're
very fortunate to be able to work with a
lot of different researchers in our
field and get a lot of feedback on
learning on what works in specific
protocols so rodents do have high energy
requirements and this is due to their
small size yet high metabolic rate
additionally rodents have very limited
fat storage to mobilize and times of
increased energy needs and this is even
more pronounced in young animals rodents
also have a very high surface area
relative to body weight so this
increases energy just required for
thermal regulation on average a mouse
will consume about three to six grams of
diet per day which is about 12 to 18
grams per hundred grand body weight and
on average a rat will consume about 15
to 30 grams of diet per day which is
about five to six grams per hundred gram
body weight that can vary again based on
the size of the strain of the rat surly
surgery does induce a hypermetabolic
state in the animals so we want to make
sure that we pay attention to nutrition
postoperatively they are in a
hypermetabolic States they do have
increased energy requirements
post-operative nutrition is important to
rotor survival and recovery after
surgery again to minimize weight loss
and protein loss and help the animals
retain to the pre return to their
preoperative body weight and metabolic
state as quickly as possible we know
that rodents do have a reduced food and
water consumption for at least one to
two days postoperatively and this can be
even longer depending on
of the surgery and trauma in the animal
so we want to do our best to minimize
impact that surgery does have on the
animal model so during surgery there are
changes that occur metabolically in the
animal specifically there is an
increased metabolic rate in the animal
and unfortunately this is occurring at a
time when the animals do have a
decreased appetite and are less likely
to eat so we see that weight loss once
the animals glycogen is depleted from
the liver the animal is going to switch
to generating new glucose in liver and
kidney and using amino acids as
substrates for this we see an increase
in both glucagon and insulin this ratio
does favor glucagon and as a result
there is a resultant hyperglycemia that
is observed this hyperglycemia is also
linked with insulin resistance in the
animals and what this does is it
decreases the uptake of glucose by
skeletal muscle and adipocytes and keeps
it available for very critical tissues
and organs that are involved in wound
healing such as a central nervous system
kidney wound tissue and hematological
cells this insulin resistance that
occurs also prevents ketogenesis or the
use of fatty acids as an energy source
so that the body does shift to breaking
down muscle protein using amino acids as
substrates for gluconeogenesis we also
see an increase in cortisol which is
released in response to stress this does
promote proteolysis and insulin
resistance so as I mentioned we see this
increase in tissue protein catabolism so
it's a hyper catabolic and
hypermetabolic state so increased
protein catabolism increase energy
requirements and this skeletal muscle
that is broken down the amino acids are
used for gluconeogenesis as I mentioned
they're also used for substrates for new
protein and tissue healing
also in the liver for the production of
acute phase response proteins which are
involved in the immune system
hematological cells and wound healing we
see it increase nitrogen loss or
negative nitrogen balance that can last
several days or even longer again
depending on the degree of injury to the
animal so there's an overall increased
need for both energy and protein in the
animals and this is all happening
because the body is placing a priority
on wound repair hoping that that's going
to occur before that breakdown in body
protein and loss of body weight becomes
a threat to the animal survival so this
next slide that I'm still having some
problems with my slides here's turn it
this next slide shows the changes that
occur in response to injury specifically
the increase in the resting metabolic
rate and the increased loss of nitrogen
or muscle protein from the body so the
top slide does show that you have
increased resting metabolic rate or
hyper metabolic rate proportional to the
degree of injury and burn injuries
really increase the metabolic rate
booths in humans and animals and this
presents a real challenge in recovering
the animals and getting them back to
their normal body weight the lower graph
shows the increase in nitrogen excretion
which is the protein loss from the body
and although there is an increased
protein turnover so increase in
synthesis and breakdown they break down
far exceeds that that is synthesized so
it's important to first talk about the
preoperative metabolic state the
nutritional status of the animal is a
very important determinant of how well
the animal is going to recover prior to
surgery so we really want to make sure
that the animals are in the best
condition preoperatively that they can
be withholding food in rodents is not
necessary
rodents do not vomit additionally it's
been demonstrated that the stomach is
emptied in about six hours in rodents so
in general it's recommended not to fast
them for more than four to six hours
there are quite profound effects of
fasting on body weight in a series of
studies done in rats they showed that
after six hours there was a five percent
loss of body weight after 12 hours there
was a nine percent loss and after 18
hours there was a thirteen percent loss
in body weight and the loss in liver
weight was even more severe it's also
important to pay attention if you do
fast animals when that food is removed
noting that animals thiet rodents are
nocturnal so they eat during the dark
phase so paying attention to how long
the animals actually have been without
food is important water should never be
withheld prior to surgery you want to
make sure the animals are well hydrated
going into surgery and a preoperative
animal jeezu has really been
demonstrated to minimize a decrease in
food intake that we see after surgery a
common complication that can affect
rodents recovering from surgery or
anesthesia is dehydration so we always
advocate not putting anything in the
water that will affect flavor and deter
the rodents from drinking you want to
make sure the water stays very palatable
so they do stay hydrated also it's
important to note that water and food
intake do go hand in hand so if an
animal stops drinking they're also
likely to stop eating so that's why it's
important for most to make sure the
animals well hydrated electrolyte
support can be a very effective and
getting animals to drink and stay
hydrated it can stimulate water
consumption and can be delivered either
in a water bottle or place in a bowl at
cage level gel products are very
successful there are a lot available
specifically for rodents these can be
both a source of food and water for the
animals this is an image showing a rat
that was being acclimated to an
electrolyte supplement prior to surgery
and you can see the rat is willingly
consuming the electrolyte supplement
that leads us into acclimation as I just
mentioned the rat in the previous slide
was being acclimated to something they
were going to receive postoperatively
acclamation to new diets or treats can
really be critical to successful
post-operative recovery it's really
important to expose animals to Coast
operative diets or treat prior to
surgical procedures the 8th edition of
the guide actually mentions the
importance of acclamation stating
regardless of whether the animals are
quarantined newly received animals
should be given a period of physiologic
behavioral and nutritional acclamation
before their use so in our case for
surgery is important not only to
acclimate the animals to their
surroundings but to also acclimate them
to anything you're going to provide them
post operatively to help them recover by
exposing animals to postoperative diets
or treats you're allowing them to
acclimate to the diet when they're
healthy it allows you the investigator
to determine what flavors or formats
each animal model prefers we know that
different strains with in mice or rats
could have different preferences in
flavor or texture or format of diets we
know that rodents particularly rats can
be Nia phobic so they're not going to
take to something the first time they
meet a day or two to get used to it and
evaluate it and the acclimation period
has really proven to increase the
acceptance of postoperative diets so
this preconditioning will help us
determine which treats will be most
effective in achieving results we can
determine flavor preferences by a simple
taste test it allows animal time to
adjust and try new treats in their cage
we have investigators that do very
simple flavor preferences they'll just
present the animal with a couple
different pellets of different flavors
and then can visually observe which they
prefer and they'll know use that flavor
postoperatively so again you can
increase the acceptability of
postoperative diets medicated treats or
enrichment for quicker recovery we
actually have facilities that say that
if the animals are not acclimated
surgery's postponed so they have found
that to be so critical and the success
of their post-operative
that they require in their protocol so I
just want to point out that nutritional
supplementation or early enteral
nutrition is a first line of defense in
helping the animals recover
postoperatively however it's not going
to completely prevent weight loss or
protein loss but it can improve calorie
and nitrogen balance during this hyper
catabolic state so our goal with enteral
nutrition or nutritional support is to
maintain body weight and protein stores
to help minimize that protein catabolism
and weight loss that occurs
postoperatively so we want to provide
calories and a nitrogen source or
protein to help facilitate protein
synthesis and the animals and provide
them energy we want to make sure the dye
is highly palatable nutrient-dense and
nutritionally complete and we want to
make sure we're giving the animal
sufficient protein to heal their wounds
and generate new tissue so we do know
that rodents are going to have a
decrease in food intake post-operatively
so we want to try our best to get them
eating as quickly as possible
postoperatively want to provide a high
quality diet soon after surgery to
prevent this calorie malnutrition and
decrease mortality as i mentioned that
hydration and feed intake are very
closely linked so we want to make sure
the animals get supplemental fluid or
electrolyte support therapy if needed
and also because it's been demonstrated
that severe pain results in loss of food
and water intake we want to make sure
the animals are not experiencing faints
a pain so they were not further
exasperatingly situation so one of the
things that we can do to get the animals
eating quicker is to stimulate their
appetite and one of the ways to do this
is to use flavorings in foods many years
ago we had worked with NIH to try to
determine what flavors will be very
successful in rodents to get them to eat
when they were not feeling well and
surprisingly one of the forerunners in
this was a bacon flavoring it's been
demonstrated to be very successful in
stimulating appetite of rodents other
flavors that work very well in rodents
are chocolate and berry and fruit
flavors so the aroma is going to help
entice them and stimulate their appetite
and the flavor can also help
aidan food intake providing an
alternative diet to their typical Chow
can also stimulate food intake just like
in humans in animals a diet with a novel
different tastes may entice rodents to
eat we know that when we're not feeling
well we tend to eat different things
than we would if we were feeling healthy
so it's the same for rodents just like
in humans as well variety can increase
food intake in ruins it's also important
to note learned food adverse ins so if I
wrote it associate feed with not feeling
well they're less likely to consume this
diet so it's really important to get to
know your animals and know what what
formats and flavors they like and are
willing to consume so if the animal is
not willing to consume a nutritionally
complete diet immediately recovering
from surgery we found that treats work
wonderful as appetite stimulants
providing them simple treats such as
dried fruits nuts seeds even peanut
butter just to stimulate their appetite
get their GI moving and then follow up
with a normal diet specific diets that
work very well postoperatively our gel
diets these are made with both food and
water so if this was the only thing the
animal were to eat they would get all
the nutrition and water they needed in a
given day another advantage of gel diets
is that they're very soft and very easy
for the animal to consume and we always
recommend for all post-operative diets
to place them at cage floor level for
animals that cannot get to the hopper so
this is really important and you'll see
this as a bullet under many of my slides
again always reminding you to provide
the post-operative diets cage level
another diet that works very well
postoperatively are purified diets these
are made with very refined pure
ingredients in simple form they're low
residue so they're very easy for the
animals to digest and absorb and have
been documented to improve
post-operative recovery as we mentioned
the animals are in a hyper catabolic and
hypermetabolic state so providing the
animals with diets higher in protein and
higher in fat work very well so if the
animal is consuming less diet having a
higher fat diet will give them those
additional calories
and the higher protein level can help
the animal recover these diets are both
calorie and nutrient dense the high-fat
diets also tend to be softer softer
diets tend to work well postoperatively
whether it's as Extreme as a liquid diet
or a soft palate or a gel or a dough
just easier for the animals to consume
and they're more willing to eat it again
placing these at cage level allows the
animal to consume it readily without
having to get to the cage hopper or the
food hopper liquid diets are very very
successful for post-operative recovery
both in humans and many different types
of animals liquid diets are made with
purified ingredients which as I
mentioned are very refined very easy for
the animals to ingest and digest they're
ideal for gastrointestinal surgery
recovery they have minimal residue
because of their efficient absorption of
nutrients so i have several examples of
the success of liquid diets in
post-operative recovery and i want to
present some of those just to give you
some some success stories and this
particular model this was an intestinal
resection model in mice specifically a
small bowel resection mice had been
receiving solid diets post-op and the
investigators observed a very high
mortality rate and they attributed this
to complications from disruption of
wound healing by the pre ingested food
they found that even if they fasted the
animals for 48 hours prior to surgery
they still solve as high mortality rate
and disruption of the wound so what they
did was they switched the mice over to a
liquid diet three days preoperatively
they gave them the same diet
postoperatively and what they documented
was that they then had a ninety-five
percent survival rate when using the
liquid diet goes pre-op and for the
recovery so this was the most
significant impact on the success of
their model was just switching the pre
and post-operative diet they then took
it a step further and looked at whether
if the liquid diet contained a high
protein level or a standard protein
level how this would affect the recovery
of the animals so the standard
protein was seventeen percent calories
from protein and the high protein was
forty-five percent calories from protein
the diets were matched in all other
nutrients and were isocaloric so they
had the same calories per milliliter of
liquid diet the author's documented that
the caloric intake was the same so there
was no difference the mice didn't
consume more of the high protein or the
standard protein diet however the weight
loss was significantly less in the
animals receiving the high protein diet
they actually returned to their
preoperative body weight on day eight
post surgery versus day 22 post surgery
so that's a pretty significant
difference and they also saw an increase
in total lean and fat mass in the high
protein group compared to the low
protein group and this is just the tip a
graph right out of their of their
publication just documenting that
difference in weight gain in the animals
in the high protein diet which is the
black line versus the standard protein
which is the blue lions is a pretty
significant difference in post-operative
weight gain that they observed this next
study shows that providing a different
enteral nutrition in the post hyperbolic
hyper catabolic state in Burns so this
is rats that received a burn injury so
showing that providing a liquid diet
post operatively really made a dramatic
difference in the recovery of the
animals in this particular study as I
mentioned the rats did receive a burn
injury they were given either a standard
route and diet or a liquid diet liquid
diet was both higher in protein and in
fat and they were parasites that the
animals did consume the same number of
calories and what they found was that
the animals that were on the liquid diet
after five weeks of healing they had
returned actually gained a little bit of
weight relative to their pre-burn weight
whereas the animals on the grain based
diet still were underweight relative to
their pre-burn wait they also documented
improved protein balance during this
hyper metabolic response to injury
higher protein in the serum and muscle
and higher acute phase response proteins
Jenner
by the liver so although this particular
study doesn't show exactly what
specifically in the liquid diet was
responsible for the increased recovery
it does show the dramatic effect that
changing your post-operative diet can
have on your recovery model and as I
mentioned that recovering from burn
injuries does really significantly
increase the metabolism in rodents so
this is a hard model to get back to
pre-burn State pre-burn on weight this
next study looks at the difference
between a purified diet versus a
standard Green Bay diet the
postoperative diets used here were a
standard purified road and I am 76 a
versus a green diet these animals were
acclimated to the diet seven days prior
to surgery and were not fasted and what
they found was rats consuming the grain
diet after their liver surgery had a
twenty to thirty percent decrease in
food intake postoperatively they did not
observe this and the animals consuming
the purified diet they continued to eat
a preoperative level further the animals
on the green diet didn't return to the
preoperative body weight until day 14
verses the animals in the purified diet
who returned by day seven interestingly
they also demonstrated that there was a
lower feed efficiency and the animals on
the green diet that's the gram of body
weight gained per the gram of diet
consumed so even at the same level of
feed take the animals on the purified
diet did put on more weight program of
diet consumed they did not see this
effect in the sham group so there was no
difference on weight gain for the green
versus the purified so this was
specifically in effect in the
post-operative state so they found the
purified diets did promote a quicker
recovery post-operatively this was this
next study was one that we did in
collaboration with taconic trying to
help rats in a category ii procedure so
they weren't receiving analg to helping
them recover or gain their body pic
regain their body weight after this
procedure quicker so there were six
groups
were matched on weight the first two
groups did not receive surgery the first
was on the regular feed and the second
received the regular feed and the
post-operative diet post-operative diet
was a soft pelleted diet with bacon
flavoring it was a higher fat and a
little bit higher in protein diet group
c and d also had surgery but they
received regular feed and d received
regular feet and moistened feed groups
enf both received the post-operative
diet the difference being that groupie
was a'kla mated two days prior to the
surgery and group f did not receive
acclimation to the post-operative diet
and what we observed was that the
animals that did receive the
post-operative diet showed less of a
loss of body weight compared to the
animals receiving the standard feet or
moistened feed and were not
significantly different from controls by
days five and seven this shows the
difference of body weight comparing
baseline to post operative day seven and
you can see the animals that did receive
the post-operative diet groups enf did
return to their preoperative body
weights at the end of the seven day
period were animals that received the
standard diet or the moistened chow did
not return to their preoperative valuate
by this period so we observed the routes
that were supplemented with the Coast
operative diet did have less body weight
loss relative to the rats on the
standard feed the return to their
preoperative body weight within five
days and the animals in the standard
feed had not returned by day seven
importantly there was no effect on the
research model development as measured
by spin rates when using the
post-operative diet so this suggests
that there was improved recovery in the
animals receiving the post-operative
diet specifically in this category
procedure in rats so as we talked about
there is an increased stress on the
animals when they are recovering from
surgery so we really want to do our best
to minimize introducing any stress
additional stress in the animals
increased stress has been implicated in
poor wound healing it can have profound
effects on the physiology of the animal
and it really can delay recovery and
increase energy requirements there was a
study out of Massachusetts General
Hospital department of surgery which did
a beautiful job documenting this
mind-body relationship in regards to
wound healing and what they found was in
rats they were looking at wound healing
after burn injury and what they found
was the rats that were either group
housed or provided with enrichment had a
much quicker recovery wound healing
compared to the animals that were singly
housed and they actually linked this to
changes in the brain responsible for
stress so they found the animals that
were either group housed or provided
enrichment did have less stress and
ultimately healed quicker compared to
the animals that were singly housed so
one of the ways that we can decrease
stress in animals postoperatively is
using edible enrichment to minimize
handling of the animals whether this be
for an assessment of pain mobility or
wound healing so in regards to pain we
know that the animals do prefer treats
and are very interested in treats so
providing these to them and seeing a
lack of interest may be an indicator
that something's wrong you can also use
the treats to see how mobile the animal
is placing treats on top of the cage or
in front of the cage and seeing if the
animal moves to them we actually had an
investigator it was very creative and
what she did was she put treats in
different corners of the cage and then
she would look the next day to see which
ones were consumed so it gave her an
idea of how mobile the animals were in
the cages you can play streets on top of
the cage to evaluate incisions or wound
healing without actually having to pick
the animals up again this allows
minimizing handling and decreased stress
tree
can stimulate feed intake and rodents
with poor appetite so again it can get
them jump-started also it can just
provide them with an opportunity of
enrichment or foraging opportunity which
we know can decrease stress in animals
it can also act as a distraction from
not feeling well or even from their
incisions these two images just so that
you can give some sort of enrichment for
any situation the animal on the Left who
can't use his paws to pick up a treat
can be given a larger block so that they
can have some form of edible enrichment
and the animal on the right prefers to
take his treats and carry him back to
his shelter on what he liked today
another way to use treats or feed to
minimize stress is to use stress free
oral dosing we know that injections and
handling of the animals do introduce
stress and dr. Lisa bune of the US Army
Research Institute she documented this
this injection stress by measuring core
body temperature and showing the
hypothermia that was introduced when
animals were injected this was
completely eliminated when the animals
were allowed to voluntarily consume the
medication in a treat so medications can
be incorporated into diets or treats in
highly palatable forms that can mask
that our tastes and odors of medications
and again it gives you an opportunity to
minimize stress from handling the
animals at a time when they're there
trying to heal there are a lot of
publications out there which document
the success of using stress free oral
dosing in different formats from
chocolate spreads to peanut butter jelly
is nutritionally complete diets and
documented the animals do consume it
some as quickly as 15 minutes or 30
minutes the drugs for this must be in
oral form you need to be able to monitor
or verify consumption and make sure that
the drug is in an appropriate
formulation and all drugs aren't
palatable so not oral drugs can be used
in this way from our experience we've
seen drugs such as
Plus born can be very difficult to mask
so just to summarize we went over
animals post-operatively are in a hyper
catabolic and hypermetabolic state so
they have an increased need for both
protein and energy they have an
increased protein turnover however the
degradation of proteins exceeding that's
what synthesized so they are in a
negative nitrogen balance things we can
do from the nutritional side is making
sure the animal is in the best state
possible preoperatively making sure the
animals hydrated providing nutritionally
complete diets or treats
post-operatively to get the animal
eating and jump started making sure we
pay attention to the composition and
form of the diet providing animals with
either liquid diets or a softer form and
making it easily accessible for them to
get to and most importantly making sure
that this diet is palatable that's
something that's going to stimulate
their appetite and they're going to want
to eat things we can do from the
enrichment side using edible enrichment
to facilitate either dosing or
monitoring of the animals and really
decreasing stress just by giving them in
a reward we had an investigator that
shared her story in regards to
enrichment she needed to monitor
improvements in dexterity in her rats
after spinal cord injury and she placed
treats in the top of the cage and the
rats had to pull it down and she was
able to monitor help dexterous they were
so after a couple of days of doing this
she found that when she walked into the
room those little paws went up for that
treat so it just shows the power of
rewarding the animals how effective it
can be on your model so next I'm going
to go over some protocols that we've
learned working with other investigators
just to give you an idea of the success
stories that we've heard this first is
just a just a really basic sample
post-operative care plan we always
recommend an acclimation to the recovery
diet at least two to three days prior to
surgery to make sure it's something
that's not novel to the animal at the
time of recovery feeding the
post-operative diet cage level for about
five to seven days providing diets that
are
whether it's a doe a soft diet a gel
diet or liquid diet and we do recommend
providing these fresh daily because they
are soft and we want to keep them that
way and keep them fresh higher moisture
products tend to go bad quicker so
providing it fresh daily is a good idea
it also gives you an idea of how much
the animals are consuming if you change
it out each day you can include a
postoperative analgesia in a treat or a
diet form if appropriate to minimize
handling we always recommend keeping the
standard feed in the hopper and keeping
your standard watering system to give
the animals option if they prefer to eat
that providing basic enrichment in the
cage such as shelter or nesting
opportunity can help decrease stress
levels which is important in recovery
and then it's a good idea to give some
edible enrichment whether giving it for
foraging or a reward or for monitoring
it can really help decrease stress
levels in the rodents this is a protocol
that was shared to us by Nancy defelice
who's been wonderful with her animals
and really creating a wonderful plan to
help her animals recover and have
minimal complications so they do icv
cannulation xin the rats and they
require a four to seven day acclimation
period to whatever they're giving the
animals postoperatively they also
acclimate them to the placebo tablets so
they do use the voluntary oral dosing in
a treat form so the animals are
applicate are acclimated to the placebo
her animals are also given some
enrichment they're given a nylon bone
nesting material and shelters
preoperatively the animals are given
their medicated tablet and some of the
gel diet they'll get postoperatively on
the day of the surgery they're getting
there getting there medicated tablet
they're getting their food cage level
and a gel diet and then they do this
post operatively for 27 days and they
report very few complications when they
have this protocol in place
the next example is from Kim Moscow at
Drexel Kim does a lot of surgeries and
studies on wound healing and she was
having some high mortality and morbidity
rates in this particular model it
involved doing wound checks quite
regularly because that was part of the
study involved putting the animals under
anesthesia to do these rumanceks so she
was seeing a lot of dehydration and loss
of body weight the animals were not
doing well so Kim put together a very
comprehensive plan to turn around her
model so what she did was she acclimated
her animals knowing that the rat sarnia
phobic she started giving a preoperative
analgesia and she also incorporated
nutrition and hydration supplements in
the cage additionally what Kim did to
facilitate these wound check is that she
started a'kla mating the rats to her by
handling them and giving them a reward
after the handling so she was able to
eliminate having to do anesthesia
putting the animals under anesthesia to
do these wound checks and it really
turned around her model she reported
minimized weight loss dehydration and an
overall decreased recovery time this is
one of her very very happy rats this
next example is out of NIH and they had
an undersized knockout model this model
was only about 3 to 5 grams body weight
post meaning they needed to have a
cranial injection at day 14 and they
were observing very significant weight
loss and the model was not viable so
they implemented a very rigorous
nutritional support plan by
incorporating pre-surgical supplements
into the protocol so the animals could
get acclimated and help get to a higher
body weight going into surgery this
included protein whey protein which is a
very good protein boost pre and post
operatively a liquid diet ensure and
fresh fruit postoperatively to increase
caloric intake and keep the animals
hydrated they included an oral
jalate supplement as well as several
forms of postoperative diets and protein
supplements they documented increased
weight gain on the Supplemental care
program and overall improved body
condition score and decreased
mortalities they were able to get a
viable model by incorporating a
post-operative nutritional
supplementation plan finally this last
example shows how to use edible
enrichment in a post surgical model this
specifically was a meniscal tear for an
oz do arthritic model and they just use
dried fruit and nutritionally complete
bacon-flavored pellets provided cage
level immediately after surgery and they
documented that these treats provided a
source of enrichment for the animals it
also gave them nutritional
supplementation so it minimize weight
loss postoperatively it has also allowed
them to do assessment of post-operative
mobility and weight bearing to see how
well the animals can move around by
putting the treats at different spaces
in the cage and observing the movement
without having to handle them they were
also able to do routine checks of the
knee incisions by placing a treat on top
of the cage and having the animals
stretch up so again without actually
having to handle the animals and they
also found that giving these treats did
provide a distraction from the incision
site so it really improved the recovery
of their animals postoperatively so as
you can see if you invest the time to
establish protocols for your research
you can see a significant improvement in
recovery get healthier animals quicker
recovery and less stress we all know
that unstressed animals provide more
reliable data and better science we know
the response of an of an animal to
surgery can be a variable itself so by
helping the atom will recover in a non
stressful environment and providing them
with that nutritional supplementation
can really improve their recovery
postoperatively thank you so much for
attending my presentation today and I'd
be happy to take any questions you may
have at this time
so the question here is is there a
reason you are using rimadyl and not
meloxicam so we have investigators that
use rimadyl we have investigators that
use meloxicam so it really just depends
on the model and the investigators needs
so the next question is are there any
specific recommendations you would have
for post-op support of rats with spinal
cord injuries again if the animals are
not able to move around in the cage very
well providing them something cage level
and liquid diets probably would be my
first line of defense for helping them
recover question did you state that the
use of pre-emptive analgesics lead to
decreased food consumption we see the
rest of us now the use of pre-emptive
Alex would prevent that decrease in food
consumption that you see post-op so
providing the animals with analgesia
prior to going into surgery can help
decrease that loss of appetite so it
will help the animals recover quicker
sorry if I was confusing on that know
how to see them us these questions
I've experienced seriously kick etic
mice that have quit eating due to tumors
or chemotherapy I'm trying to see the
rest of this sorry I'm having a hard
time seeing the rest of the question one
second here okay now I see it so I have
experience seriously kinetic mice that
have quit eating due to tumors or
chemotherapy just by that it made a
recovery just by giving them the big and
soft do so thanks for sharing that yes
there was post-operative diets that are
highly palatable really can turn around
your animals next question after
abdominals sorry after abdominal surgery
on rodents a high-calorie supplement
like nutria cow is applied to pieces of
food in place in an easy-to-reach place
like the corner of their cage the
animals crawl around on their bellies
upon coming out of anesthesia there is a
high chance that the animals crawling
over the nutria cow and getting it on
their non-continuous abdominal sutures
if the animals are housed in pairs is
there a risk of the rats chewing on
their cage mates neutrik held sutures
and causing them to come undone if so is
there another strategy you would suggest
for this situation post-op so the liquid
diet if you have a liquid diet you can
feed them in liquid diet feeding tubes
or you could feed it in a water bottle
so that may prevent some of it from
getting on their bodies the liquid diet
feeding tubes only comes out when the
animal licks the diet out so that may
prevent it from getting on the animals
if the you know if the nutria Cal is not
working possibly trying
diet or a gel diet that may not get on
the animals as much in terms of
post-operative wound repair diet which
supplement was most efficient to
accelerate this process and immunity so
I've seen the most success in the
literature on using the liquid diets
they seem to work really well and
helping the animals recover so I would
say the liquid diets whether it's a
rodent nutritional complete rodent form
where I've even seen success you mean
using the human available forms so what
sort of post-operative nutritional
support would you recommend for models
of head and neck cancer who have oral
tumors surgically removed again using
the the liquid diet may be your best bet
we typically recommend soft diets for
any animals that have difficulty chewing
or consuming food but I would recommend
using the liquid diets a public would be
the easy for the animals and they're
getting their food in water in one
source is there a recipe for jello with
whey protein and what are quantities
added yes I do have a reference for that
and I'd be happy to email you the
formulation that was used to make that
high protein supplement for the road so
I certainly can email that to you so you
can try that in your model
will you provide this PowerPoint as a
download I'd love to have this to show
some of our researchers thank you very
much yes I'd be more than happy to share
that with you and I can certainly send
you a copy of the presentation next
question is what would you suggest for
rodents that are in metabolism cages
some of these metabolism cages might
allow you to use a liquid diet if you
can hang the feeder in there that also
can let you rip using the liquid diets
typically in the feeders you can dock
them document exactly how much the
animals or consuming which I know is
important for these types of studies so
that might be a good approach here next
question is there any concern of placing
gel on the floor of the cage and this
comes up often but it's widely used in a
very common method of delivering the gel
diets typically they're kept in the
container that they come in so it may be
a small plastic container or they can be
transferred out into a petri dish or
bowl again just making it easy for the
animals to get to next question is how
do you medicate the treats there's
different approaches that have been used
the medications can actually be
incorporated in to the formula prior to
manufacturing so that they're
homogeneously mixed in and then you can
give the small treat to the animals with
the medication in there we've actually
seen investigators that will pipette the
medication on top of a tree and the
treats will just absorb it in and then
they feed it that way other
investigators mix the medication in with
a liquid diet or in peanut butter or a
chocolate spread so there are different
options of doing this depending on on
your protocol and your needs next
question is how to offer the liquid
diets to the rodents the liquid diets
can be fed in liquid diet feeding tubes
again these have an opening on the
bottom that allows the animal to lick
the diet
and it's very low towards the bottom of
the cage so it's easy for the animals to
get out depending on the formulation
some of them can be put into a water
super bottle so they can get it out that
way next question we place the gel die
in the floor of the cage yeah ultimately
this is up to the policies at your
institution but if you have a good
justification for providing the diet to
the animals caged level putting it on a
dish or a bowl because it will help them
recover generally it's not an issue
getting this through do you know of any
nutrition enrichment that is calorically
neutral we do metabolism research and I
don't think dried fruit or bacon would
be a good idea if you really want to
control and know exactly what your
animals are consuming using purified
diets can be the best approach they're
very reproducible and consistent again
using a liquid diet that's in purified
form can allow you to monitor feed
intake so that these diets are used in a
lot of nutritional research and
nutritional studies so that may be a
good option for your protocol what is
your weighing routine postoperatively
daily or do you leave them be if they
purify and due to potential stress of
weighing yes if the animals appear to be
the animals appear to be consuming their
diet and you can weigh their feed intake
as a way of knowing if they are
consuming it appear to be mobile and not
experiencing any pain they don't need to
be weighed routinely typically in the
research I presented they were being
weighed routinely because that was you
know part of the of the research design
but it's it's not necessary
okay next question what appetite
stimulant was used in the post-operative
care protocol so the different appetite
stimulants that can be used you can use
flavored treats nutritionally complete
treats or what works really well is a
very small dried fruit we have found
that to be very successful not only in
rodents but also in rabbits and primates
as well so just using some dried fruit
works very very well great presentation
thank you so much my question it is
related to an infectious model the
animal receive the pathogen and in some
period of time we sacrifice how we can
relieve some of the symptoms of the
infection in general one or two days of
them and mostly fever so from a diet
standpoint I'm not sure if you're
finding that the animals are consuming
feed if they're not I would try
switching them over to a post-operative
diet and see if just getting the animals
eating can help them recover a little
quicker
again the question what appetite
stimulants are you using we're using
dried fruits nuts seeds and flavored
pellets and treats and they have that
bacon flavoring in it a postoperative
diet with flavoring can really help
stimulate the appetite okay
that answers all the questions if anyone
has any other questions feel free to
email me and I'd be happy to send you a
response or anything if something should
come up later thank you so much for
listening to my presentation today and
enjoy the rest of your day take care